la reine elizabeth 2 a passé sa vie en
représentation et devant les caméras
pourtant à bien des égards elle reste
mystérieuse et hind matic le réalisateur
britannique loi jimmy choo à qui on doit
le film coup de foudre à notting hill a
plongé dans les milliers d'heures
d'archivés publics et privés de la
souveraine pour assembler un portrait en
pièces détachées
le résultat est un documentaire décalé
sans narration qui ne ressemble à rien
ce qui a été fait sur la reine et qu'il
arrive elle sous un nouveau jour à
l'honneur d'une étudiante quand elle est
jeune même jeune reine plus le temps
avance plus elle devient
jeune grave
retenue alors on voit cette évolution
c'est à dire c'est une femme qui est un
peu prisonnière de chant de
wenzhou
le film elizabeth regard singulier
enchaîné entre croiser des moments de la
vie de la reine capter aux vidéos
classées par chapitre de sa passion pour
les chevaux au drame qu'elle a dû
affronter en passant par le poids
écrasant de la couronne rennes cannes
des images royal toutes plus
exceptionnel et surréalistes les unes
que les autres qui mises côte à côte
trace un portrait singulier de cette
femme de devoir moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
oui vraiment que c'est surprenant
créatif insolite surréaliste mais le
surréalisme du bon cinéma
le résultat est irrévérencieux les
respectueux le fait de rester à la
surface en reprenant uniquement des
images existantes permet de gto regard
différent sur sa vie et son destin
exceptionnel
alors que la reine s'apprête à célébrer
son jubilé de platine le film elizabeth
regard singly lui permet de prendre
pleinement conscience que cette femme de
96 ans a été témoin et actrice
privilégié de tous les bouleversements
qui ont transformé le monde au cours du
dernier siècle
[Musique]
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal